edit site bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors est ce
qu'on en sait un peu plus sur les
raisons de cette fusillade
alors écoutez de prime abord je commence
aujourd'hui c'est que aujourd'hui c'est
un énième règlement de comptes sur la
commune de marseille malheureusement les
détails dacourt tomba pour l'instant
communiquer et la police judiciaire des
services criminelle de la police
judiciaire de marseille qui en charge de
l enquête qui devra effectivement
éclaircir nous en sommes sûrs que sont
le motif et est la raison pour
effectivement commettre un tel acte avec
des armes de guerre devenu président en
pleine journée aux abords d'une école
maternelle alors le premier aussi vital
de la victime étaient engagés à
l'arrivée des secours quel est son état
de santé à l'heure actuelle on le
connaît alors que l'on tend
effectivement l'état de tenter pour les
temps étaient une individuelle et à
humaniser il n'y a aucune garantie
qu'ils s'en sortent un m faut savoir
quand même que tu es qulqu'un franchi un
cap dans l'ensemble c'est le plan
particulier de mise en sûreté
donc elle s'est déclenchée effectivement
par l'école sachant que ce plan général
et surtout dédié pour les cas d'attentât
et des grands candidats taxi ni convoi
imaginez vous un peu effectivement dans
l'appréhension et la peur du but du
corps enseignant les parents qui étaient
aux abords sont pas les leurs de la
sortie de ce que deux sociétés d'antan
et effectivement nous avons présents sur
place
c'était ce que les armes de guerre dont
les nationalités crise importante
c'est vrai qu'on en parle lui qui
aujourd'hui nous ont peur de rien et
malheureusement sur la commune de
marseille c'est un énième règlement de
compte on voit effectivement des
renforts sur des communes telles que lee
telles que lille effectivement nuit on
connait souci tu nous aides délinquance
maintenant les terribles de france va
être courues en effectif façon
conséquente pardon notre administration
car et je rappellerai que les
mutualisations d'arrondissement sur les
sur l'agglomération marseille on peut
disparaître les piscines en certaines
certains certains policiers qui m'ont de
terrain sur sa faim d'arrondissement et
les bd d'intervention ils multiplièrent
une façon exponentielle alors des armes
de guerre vous
vié à proximité d'une école comment ça
se fait qu'on en est arrivé là
aujourd'hui
malheureusement cette école située dans
les quartiers nord de marseille
on sait qu'il aime méritas numérique est
connue souterraine qui existe et qu'il
ya des quartiers de reconquête
républicaine non c'est quand j'entends
dire il y en eut en place avec des
unités peut-être que les psp qui sort il
a 30 confessions r6 curé des quartiers
mais je me cache pas que le trafic est
tellement sexualité dans certains
quartiers il figurait effectivement du
quartier les familles entières
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un travail qui est
structurelle et toute réponse
structurelle et pas conjoncturel et pour
cela il faudra des effectifs de police
qui occuperont le terrain de plus en
plus donc pas seulement effectivement
que du répressif avec des unités que la
belgique sur un travail formidable
justin a impressionné sur les quartiers
nord de marseille
mais en plus c'est pétillant des
îlotiers de terrain qui sont à même
d'établir en plus souvent et sur
lesquelles on la crème l'attitude
professionnelle pour voir sécurité les
lieux en tout temps des coups de feu à
l'armé de guerre à marseille ces
quotidiens aujourd'hui
alors effectivement malheureusement en
est une autre notre cité phocéenne et
sans vouloir faire de marché bashing est
connu c'est qu'ils manquent pour
l'avènement de compte maintenant on a
quand même passé un cap et je le précise
parce que c'est la nuit et moi j'ai raté
deux nuits dans une allée sombre
effectivement où il a peu ou pas ce
baron de deux témoins une paire qu'on
présente donc en pleine journée
il est 16 heures il nicolas côté les
parents sera lourd ils allaient chercher
leurs enfants pour partir en week-end
par contre aucun cas merci beaucoup et
décident d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et je rappelle que vous êtes délégué du
syndicat unité sgp police à marseille